[Musique]
voir les enfants capitale je peux jeter
l'autre mais bien sûr nounours tu es
bien agitée ce soir par traverser
intérêt capital jeu tellement envie de
retrouver mes petits amis et bien je
vous donne la permission de descendre
matelots merci patron pardon merci
capteur a tout de suite on le cheval à
tribord hop hop hop hop hop hop hop tous
sur le pont on peut rentrer une course
de bateaux moment les petits bateaux
dans les petits bateaux enfants sur
l'eau ont-ils de jambes et un cinéma qui
ne serait pas maman les p'tits bateaux
qui pend sur l'eau ont-ils d'un torero
d'état s'il n'avait pas que tu vas y
agirait pas
maman le petit bâton qui vont sur l'eau
une et voilà je gagnais je suis arrivé
le premier regret voilà patron j'avais
je me sauve les enfants mon capital veut
que je remonte à mort nicolas animathlon
bonne nuit matelots la pêche toi tu fait
leurs gros des
[Musique]
et
bonne nuit les enfants
me voici capital l'escale à terre a été
brève alors en route le nounours ah vous
offre je lève lors nous sommes paru
pas de nuit un peu pour eux
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]